Jake:就像昨天的那个一样会吗
Jake: Like the one from yesterday, right?
Lucia: 啊procred有录屏的
Lucia: Ah, procreate has screen recording
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Lucia: 虽然我没有带iPad
Lucia: Although I didn't bring my iPad
Lucia: 所以没有办法用procreate了
Lucia: So I can't use procreate
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's alright.
Lucia: 嘿好了好了好了   我房间大概就是这个样子的
Lucia: Hey, alright, alright. This is pretty much how my room looks.
Jake:没关系剧组报销一台我们
Jake: No worries, the crew will reimburse for one.
Jake:哈哈哈没有没有
Jake: Haha, no, no.
Lucia: 真的吗
Lucia: Really?
Jake:假的
Jake: Just kidding.
Lucia: 那我现在立刻就下单
Lucia: Then I’ll place the order right now.
Lucia: 这个软件我都买了
Lucia: I already bought the software.
Lucia: 我可以先下到新的那个上面
Lucia: I can download it on the new one.
Alice:procreate这个软件可以买一下吗剧组
Alice: Can the crew buy the Procreate software?
Jake:还没有没有没钱
Jake: Not yet, no money.
Jake:这多少钱
Jake: How much is it?
Alice:98块钱
Alice: 98 yuan.
Lucia: 哎现在98了
Lucia: Oh, it’s 98 now?
Lucia: 68吗不是
Lucia: Wasn’t it 68?
Alice:以前多少
Alice: How much was it before?
Lucia: 88好像 98不记得了
Lucia: I think it was 88 or 98, I don’t remember.
Lucia: 我买的时候对是个8结尾的数字
Lucia: When I bought it, the price ended with an 8.
Lucia: 但是具体多少我忘了
Lucia: But I forgot the exact amount.
Lucia: 不是一是个
Lucia: It wasn’t 1, it was...
Alice:我也记得是个8的数字
Alice: I also remember it ending with an 8.
Jake:这是干哈的
Jake: What’s it for?
Lucia: 就是那个
Lucia: It’s for...
Lucia: 嗯可以画画
Lucia: Um, you can draw with it.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Lucia: 其实也可以做动画
Lucia: Actually, you can also make animations.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 但是我水平太差了做不了动画
Lucia: But my skills are too poor to make animations.
Lucia: 哈哈这位妹子应该可以
Lucia: Haha, this girl should be able to.
Alice:我
Alice: Me?
Lucia: 她选那个
Lucia: She chose that one.
Lucia: 我应该叫你中文还是叫
Lucia: Should I call you by your Chinese name or...
Alice:好
Alice: It’s fine.
Jake:应该叫你什么
Jake: What should I call you?
Jake:我也没整明白
Jake: I’m not sure either.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Tasha: 薇薇
Tasha: Tasha.
Jake:薇薇
Jake: Tasha.
Tasha: 薇薇
Tasha: Tasha.
Lucia: 好的薇薇应该可以
Lucia: Alright, Tasha should be able to.
Jake:只叫薇薇是吗
Jake: Just call her Tasha, right?
Jake:好嘞微微
Jake: Alright, Tasha.
Tasha: ok
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Tasha: 口水擦一擦
Tasha: Wipe your drool.
Jake:可以问问管家
Jake: You can ask the housekeeper.
Jake:就是这边的人
Jake: Just the person here.
Jake:能不能帮你把
Jake: See if they can help you.
Tasha: 试图获取一些灵感
Tasha: Trying to get some inspiration.
Lucia: 哈哈哈试图偷盗一些灵感
Lucia: Hahaha, trying to steal some inspiration.
Jake:帮你帮你
Jake: Help you, help you.
Jake:把床给卸了
Jake: Take the bed apart.
Jake:额呵呵呵
Jake: Ugh, hehehe.
Jake:把这个床给挪开
Jake: Move this bed away.
Jake:不知道能不能
Jake: Not sure if we can.
Tasha: 好像就是这样子的
Tasha: Seems like that's it.
Tasha: 一个房间
Tasha: One room.
Tasha: 呵呵呵
Tasha: Hehehe.
Tasha: 抄作业中
Tasha: Copying homework.
Alice:我们俩房间不太一样抄不了
Alice: Our rooms aren't the same, can't copy.
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Hehe.
Jake:一般抄作业
Jake: Usually copying homework.
Jake:是别人做完的抄吧
Jake: Is done after someone finishes it.
Lucia: 这个从过程就开始抄
Lucia: This one is copying from the start.
Lucia: 就万一被老师问到
Lucia: In case the teacher asks.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 你就跟他说出来你是怎么做的
Lucia: You can explain how you did it.
Lucia: 哈哈也是
Lucia: Haha, true.
Jake:也是
Jake: True.
Tasha: 抄作业他还扔吗
Tasha: Does he still throw copied homework away?
Jake:对我们先下载那个软件
Jake: Yeah, let's download that software first.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Tasha: 这是我的房间
Tasha: This is my room.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 呵呵呵
Tasha: Hehehe.
Jake:免户型一起抄是吧我们哈哈哈
Jake: Copying layout together, right? Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈户型抄不了
Lucia: Hahaha, can't copy the layout.
Katrina: 行抄不了
Katrina: Yeah, can't copy.
Alice:然后直接直接从淘宝把图片下载下来
Alice: Then just download the pictures from Taobao directly.
Alice:然后贴上去哈哈
Alice: And paste them up, haha.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Tasha: 也可以
Tasha: That works too
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed
Jake:我这房间我是装潢完了
Jake: I finished decorating this room
Jake:我是
Jake: I am
Alice:就你赛博风
Alice: It's all cyber style
Lucia: 哈哈你就赛博朋克风
Lucia: Haha, you're going for the cyberpunk look
Jake:赛博朋克风
Jake: Cyberpunk style
Jake:确实装饰了我一晚上哈哈
Jake: Yeah, it took me all night to decorate, haha
Lucia: 很暴力细微你可以再加点什么彩灯啊什么
Lucia: It's quite intense. Maybe you could add some more colored lights or something
Alice:没关系
Alice: It's okay
Jake:额呵呵更赛博了
Jake: Haha, even more cyber
Lucia: 染色了都
Lucia: It's all dyed
Alice:对对对
Alice: Yes, yes
Jake:更赛博了
Jake: Even more cyber
Tasha: 老自由了
Tasha: So free
Jake:更睡不了觉了
Jake: Can't sleep even more now
Alice:好累啊想洗澡了
Alice: I'm so tired, I want to take a shower
Alice:洗
Alice: Shower
Jake:现在呢行啊
Jake: Now? Sure
Jake:可以啊
Jake: Go ahead
Tasha: 去吧
Tasha: Go ahead
Jake:下班吧
Jake: Let's call it a day
Tasha: 现在
Tasha: Now
Alice:这个能点了
Alice: Can I turn this on
Jake:下班吧下班吧
Jake: Let's call it a day, let's call it a day
Lucia: 哦太好了那我就上去洗衣服
Lucia: Oh great, then I'll go do the laundry
Alice:手机呢
Alice: Where's my phone
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Alice:在这
Alice: Here it is
Katrina: 关机
Katrina: Turn it off
Katrina: 进入休眠状态
Katrina: Enter sleep mode
Jake:可以下班
Jake: You can go now
Tasha: 好刀郎拜拜
Tasha: Alright, goodbye Daolang
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Jake:今日杀青
Jake: That's a wrap for today
Katrina: 唉我这断了吗
Katrina: Did I get disconnected
Jake:没有断但是没关系
Jake: No, but it's fine
Katrina: 他怎么显示
Katrina: How does it show
Katrina: 呃
Katrina: Uh
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
Lucia: 是不是要弄数据进去了
Lucia: Are we supposed to input the data now?
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes
Katrina: 要complete一下
Katrina: We need to complete it
Jake:complete一下
Jake: Complete it
Lucia: ok
Lucia: Okay
Lucia: 他有新的数据
Lucia: He has new data
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 发送更久
Lucia: Sending takes longer
Jake:哦不用不用不用管了不用管了
Jake: Oh, no need, no need, don't worry about it
Jake:我直接倒
Jake: I'll just pour it directly
Alice:哎这还有俩凤
Alice: Hey, there are two more pineapples
Alice:三个凤梨
Alice: Three pineapples
Jake:谢谢谢谢
Jake: Thank you, thank you
Jake:哎你没带对吧
Jake: Hey, you didn't bring it, right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake:嗯谢谢
Jake: Hmm, thanks
Lucia: 好了不用谢
Lucia: It's okay, no need to thank
Katrina: 吓我一跳
Katrina: It scared me
Katrina: 他刚刚提示我说蓝牙怎么怎么回事
Katrina: It just prompted me about the Bluetooth issue
Katrina: 要更新我还没录上
Katrina: It needs updating, but I haven't recorded it yet
Katrina: 点开一看还是有的
Katrina: When I opened it, it was still there
Jake:嗯哼
Jake: Uh-huh
Katrina: 嘿嘿
Katrina: Hehe
Katrina: 500的衣服可以买好多哎
Katrina: With 500 bucks, you can buy a lot of clothes
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake:这边就15万
Jake: Over here, it's 150,000
消费：呵
Consumer: Huh
Jake:15万
Jake: 150,000
Alice:15万
Alice: 150,000
Katrina: 你们买啥装饰啊
Katrina: What decorations are you buying?
Tasha: 今天晚上就要开始看了
Tasha: We'll start looking tonight
Jake:呃可以看一看
Jake: Uh, you can take a look
Jake:然后我还是聊一聊
Jake: And we can still chat about it
Jake:因为你们最好是能有一个剧情
Jake: Because it's best if you have a storyline
Tasha:统一的
Tasha: Unified
Jake:或者说你们有一个主
Jake: Or at least a main theme
Jake:不同的主题之类的
Jake: Different themes or something like that
Lucia: 有一个逻辑性的房间那一定会
Lucia: Having a logical room will definitely
Lucia: 那那就是互相交流一下设计理念
Lucia: That means sharing design ideas with each other
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alice:主要是墙上对贴
Alice: Mainly it's about the wall decorations.
Lucia: 有一个剧情啊
Lucia: There's a storyline.
Jake:呃或者一个主线
Jake: Uh, or maybe a main plot.
Jake:或者
Jake: Or...
Lucia: 像机器人总动员那样可以吗
Lucia: Like WALL-E, is that okay?
Lucia: 不是就是因为这个电影里面
Lucia: No, I mean, because in this movie,
Lucia: 他牵扯了很多场景的变化
Lucia: it involves a lot of scene changes.
Alice:爱丽丝梦游仙境风
Alice: Like Alice in Wonderland style.
Lucia: 就是机器人总动员
Lucia: Just like WALL-E.
Lucia: 呃对也可以
Lucia: Uh, yeah, that works too.
Lucia: 但是机器人总动员会
Lucia: But WALL-E is more...
Lucia: 更更更像世界地球的主题因为他本身就是一个环保主题
Lucia: It's more like the theme of Earth because it's an environmental theme.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: That works.
Jake:是命题作文吧
Jake: It's like a thematic writing.
Jake:或者话题作文吧
Jake: Or a topic essay.
Lucia: 就可以可以
Lucia: Yeah, that works.
Lucia: 就某个人可能是废土风格
Lucia: Someone might have a post-apocalyptic style.
Lucia: 然后因为就是在这个电影里面
Lucia: And because in this movie...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm.
Lucia: 是人类到太空都不重要可以再来一下
Lucia: Humans going to space isn't important, let's do it again.
Alice:家有儿女里面那个给
Alice: The one in "Home with Kids" where...
Lucia: 然后在太空里面跳舞
Lucia: And dancing in space.
Alice:那星星你记得吗
Alice: That star, do you remember?
Katrina: 那个
Katrina: That one...
Alice:家有儿女
Alice: "Home with Kids."
Katrina: 我要编一下我自己的
Katrina: I need to make up my own.
Katrina: 本来就是乱糟糟的还得给他想一个
Katrina: It was messy, I need to think of one.
Jake:嗯对对
Jake: Mm, yeah, yeah.
Jake:就是要把这牛逼给吹出来
Jake: We need to hype this up.
Jake:吹一吹吧
Jake: Let's hype it up.
Katrina: 对我要那一束花上去
Katrina: Yeah, I need that bouquet.
Jake:嗯，好的
Jake: Mm, okay.
Alice:想洗澡了
Alice: I want to take a shower.
Tasha: 走吧
Tasha: Let's go.
Alice:蛋糕鞋
Alice: Platform shoes.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.